crolo lucifer embodies both jesus and
the devil and yet at the bottom of his
at first glance paradoxical view of life
and people there is an incredibly strong
and surprisingly unreligious message
about power and how it tends to warp
good intentions and love into cruelty
and inhumanity
[Music]
this makes chrolo a case study of
extremist human behavior and given all
the deep concepts explored in his
character it is no wonder that it's easy
to misunderstand what his character is
actually about is he a higher being with
a higher purpose as his powers and
determination suggests or simply a
fanatic that uses his beliefs as
justification for his horrendous deeds
because to me belonging to the trinity
of godly villains that togashi has
created each of them explores a
different aspect of power and evil as
you'll remember from his video hisoka is
an exploration of hedonism and
sociopathy
the idea that humanity is special as
well as the dark implications of pride
and arrogance
and pretty effortlessly continuing that
pattern i think that krolow explores the
themes of power and evil from a very
unique perspective as well religion or
to be more precise the belief into a
higher purpose to me crolo highlights
both the best and the worst in religious
practice and belief in a story exploring
human morality with crolo togashi makes
the most direct statement as to what it
means to be morally good or bad and no
matter if you're christian or not or
actually religious or not understanding
crolo will show you why you love hunter
hunter so damn much because as you'll
find out i'm a bit of a fan myself
now one thing i noticed quickly after
getting more and more into anime was
that religious themes are not exactly a
rarity in the genre and given japan's
own culture it's no big surprise that
especially zen buddhism and shintoism
are part of many popular stories santa
hunter is no exception to this rule only
that as usual i believe it deals with
the associated ideas and concepts on a
much more fundamental and at least for
me much more interesting level however
with crolo it also explores a religion
that i rarely see integrated into other
stories at least on such a level of
understanding christianity
[Music]
you definitely already know all the
obvious connections that associated with
chrollo there is the reverse cross
tattooed in perfect post malone fashion
on his forehead that is also stitched on
the back of his robe this reverse cross
is both associated with saint peter but
also the antichrist also known as the
devil or lucifer which who would have
thought is just one letter short of
crolo's last name the phantom troop that
as we will see is a big part of
crowler's identity consists of 13
members just as jesus and his 12
apostles with hisoka representing judas
and his betrayal
[Music]
and just like jesus chrollo sees himself
on a divine mission even though he
doesn't seem to know what exactly that
mission is and even if he knew at some
point he seems to have forgotten it by
now now right from the start being
willing to sacrifice himself for his
followers and taking no real interest in
worldly possessions he didn't really
follow my expectations of a typical bad
guy but at the same time clearly does
some horrendous things
[Music]
and for me it was this atmosphere of
higher purpose and moral ambiguity that
give krolow his undeniably intriguing
and mysterious presence so it's fair to
say i believe that the religious hints
here aren't exactly subtle the point
however i think is because in some ways
togashi portrays crollo as christ and in
others as the antichrist he can both
value the lives of his comrades but at
the same time slaughter wholesale
without the blink of an eye so let's
talk about the deep message behind
crolo's character but first a break real
quick i want to talk about prvpn the
sponsor of today's video thank you prvpn
for sponsoring this video there is still
no camera there now unless you've been
living under a rock or have been amish
until last week first of all congrats on
making it to the internet but secondly
you will probably know what a vpn does
it allows you to change your ip address
and reroute all your internet traffic
through an encrypted tunnel this way you
can hike your online activity from
anyone who might want to get their hands
on your data or you might simply want to
watch netflix or crunchyroll when
certain content is blocked in your
country now out of all the many vpn
providers out there pia is definitely
one of the most transparent and reliable
ones it's highly customizable none of
your data is stored and there's even a
30 day money back guarantee should you
change your minds so if you want to
browse safely and support my channel at
the same time use my link in the
description below to get pr vpn for 83
off that's less than 3 bucks a month and
2 extra months on top for free now we
don't really know much about crolo's
childhood and why he relies so
incredibly much on fate all we really
know is that he's from meteor city which
has a lot of mystery build up around it
and which we know is a place where
people throw other people away
[Music]
play so dark and terrible that some
don't even believe it exists now even
for me it's not so hard from a
psychological lens to see why someone
who grew up in such an environment would
tell themselves that fate governs
everything and at the same time look for
a higher purpose in life growing up in a
world of suffering and pain this can be
a real source of hope and stability all
the things you're going through have a
reason and all the morally questionable
things you have to do in order to
survive are not your fault but part of a
greater plan and in this darkest of
places crolo forms the spiders a sort of
family that shares his beliefs and is a
community of people who care for protect
and respect each other a real chance to
cast aside all their pain and hardship
[Music]
and so the group and its cause becomes
everyone's purpose i'm sure no matter if
you go to a service or not this is a
concept you'll probably recognize from
religion in fact it's arguably the most
important part for many believers having
a community of people who share your
beliefs and help you through times of
darkness and hardship it's also no
surprise then that chrollo is so
obsessed with neon's ability to predict
one's fate seeking her out was the only
time he ever diverted his attention from
their mission in york new city
[Music]
believe that everything is predetermined
by fate leads to his jesus-like ability
to forgive and accept as well most
strikingly he doesn't see judas in other
words hisoka as a traitor once he starts
hunting down members of the troop and
even himself because hisoka has in his
eyes no control over his own life it has
all been written beforehand hisoka is
basically just playing his role so why
in the world would crollo hate him if
it's not his fault in the first place
and of course forgiveness and acceptance
are universally important concepts that
are taught by many religions so up to
this point in my mind chrollo embodies
some of the best things about faith
finding an altruistic purpose in life
giving that purpose to others like him
forming a caring community looking for a
better life and being forgiving to
others the jesus side of crollow this is
the messiah the chosen one
no he's not but given all that there is
no denying that this is the person we're
talking about here
crollo is one of the major antagonists
in the story even though interestingly
enough he only touches without main
characters very scarcely in fact
karapika and hisoka are the only
characters whose arcs are deeply
involved with crollo which is of course
intriguing because hisoka is himself a
major antagonistic force and be honest i
know you love two great villains
fighting each other just as much as i do
even though they both fall on the
murderous lunatic end of the chart they
vary quite a bit in their motivations
and values chrollo and hisoka are jesus
and judas unshakeable stability versus
deliberate chaos no value to a single
human life so i might as well kill them
versus human life is the only thing that
gives my actions value so i might as
well kill them
after all hisoka is the embodiment of
lust one of the seven deadly sins
and if hisoka is lust crolo is
greed now he likes to give up the
appearance of the selfless leader that
doesn't need anything and yet he is
greedy beyond limits he wants the money
he wants vast knowledge he wants all the
worldly things crolo was a man with
nothing who now wants
everything someone so obsessed with
human nature to the point where he will
use his obsession to manipulate another
person to get what he wants from them he
instilled himself to read books and
observe the people around him even using
these books to pick certain personality
traits for himself that he finds
suitable most telling however is of
course though his name
as we all know nen usually reflects the
user's personality really well and i was
shocked to find out that chrollo has the
greediest nen ability of them all
stealing other people's powers what
turns crolo's good intentions and
beliefs against themselves is his
complete and unquestioning faith in them
chrollo is convinced that everything is
predetermined everyone has their fixed
role to play and thus it doesn't really
matter what he or anyone does since it's
fate guiding his hand anyway
fully subscribing to his beliefs as you
should be to my videos means that to
crollo humans are nothing but puppets
and he uses this belief as a
justification for all the atrocities he
commits and since he has incredible
power he sees himself in the privileged
position above other humans chosen by
fate to fulfill the most special of
roles
he thinks he's jesus now interestingly
enough what chrollo really wants just
like hisoka and meruem is fill the hole
in their heart the deep dark emptiness
within them that threatens to drown them
hisoka fills this with kicks looking for
things that make him feel excited and
alive by risking his own life and making
other people feel like [ __ ] as well
again more on that in his video oh yeah
meruem actually meets komugi overcomes
his pride and manages to fill this hole
before dying and crolo clings to his
destined role in the world and the
belief that everything he does has a
higher purpose that there is a reason
for all the pain and suffering in the
world and carrying out his role he will
be the savior of all
now the phantom troop means so much to
crollo because these people are all that
really matters to him on a human level
they are his true family and purpose but
even though he acknowledges this himself
he still tries to push himself away from
others and cast his human side away
instead of embracing his humanity and be
vulnerable he tries to make himself
something more and i think that this
approach to life represents the darkest
side of religion and other doctrines in
general when you follow a belief so
radically and without question that you
lose sight of the original good intent
it's a striking critique by togashi of
all the violence that has been committed
in the name of gods and states and
political systems throughout history
basically seeing oneself above others
and believing oneself to be the only one
that truly understands how the world
works or borrowing from another popular
franchise doing it for the greater goods
i'm sure you already know in your gut
why chrollo and extremist beliefs in any
doctrine are problematic but let me tell
you anyway it is objectively immoral
it's immoral to murder in the name of a
higher purpose or the belief that all is
predetermined hunter hunter is famous
for exploring morality through
characters that feel real because they
are morally grey however i think it
would be a grave misconception to think
that hunter hunter believes that there
is no such thing as morality in fact the
opposite is true what togashi shows
through the actions of all his
characters is that there is many ways to
act good or badly even within a
character
[Music]
but in the end what determines a moral
action is how it affects human
well-being you might have heard the
famous phrase kogito ergosome i think
therefore i am what this sentence really
means is that we all have no way to tell
what is actually real the world might be
a simulation you could just be a brain
in a jar or like crolo things everything
is guided by god or by fate we just
don't know the only thing you can be
sure of in this moment right now is that
it feels like something to be you the
fact that you are experiencing something
right now is the only thing you know
really exists and so whether you suffer
right now or not is the only thing that
really matters human well-being is what
matters the well-being of all conscious
creatures is what matters even if we had
no control over our lives
and so treating humans as puppets and
killing them for a higher purpose goes
against the highest purpose there is an
objective morality and the fact that we
had to go this deep to solve why he's
evil is why crollo is one of my favorite
villains ever however to really
understand how togashi sees evil you'll
need to watch my video on hisoka here as
well